I came across articles that showed that
the key thing you can do to reduce
population growth is actually improve
health and I thought that's the only
thing that really counts this is a bit
scary we go from less than a billion in
1800 and then 3 4 5 6 and 7.4 billion
where we are today is happening even
faster Nigeria is headed to be the third
largest country in the world 800 Million
by the end of the century so actually
China will have shrunk by them is the
population going to get so big that
feeding everybody and maintaining the
environment is going to be impossible
particularly as people get richer they
tend to eat more meat if we don't do
anything this sector will actually grow
over time so you're saying not just the
fact that there's more people and a
larger population but as people move up
towards the middle class they want to
consume more meat the one that has gone
better than I would have expected 5
years ago is this work to make what's
called artificial meat do you eat it as
well or do you like it
[Music]
absolutely eating insects is Common
Place in lots of the world it's just
never caught on in the US but some
entrepreneurs think we're ready I'm
Nicole Kidman and I am going to eat a
four course meal of bugs so all things
bugs is my biotechnology company that I
founded in 2011 primarily it got started
to develop a food product for malous
children using insects as a major food
source this is a powder derived from the
meal worm and it's a insect protein just
been approved by the EU for human
consumption I am here to reveal my
hidden talent eating micro livestock
corn worms they're still
alive extraordinary Bill Gates is on a
crusade against Meats he wants to eat
plant-based meat lab grown meat and now
he he even wants you to eat literal bugs
no really he actually invested in not
one but two startups that are
researching how to make bug protein to
feed the world after all this guy is
definitely the guy you want to take
Health advice from but why why is he so
hellbent on dictating what you can put
in your mouth is he really that
convinced that he knows how to live your
life better than you do spoiler alert
yes stay dangerous and get ready to eat
some
[Music]
bugs in 2012 the bill in Melinda Gates
Foundation quietly donated $100,000 to a
startup called All Things bugs LLC
sounds scrumptious right the company had
humble beginnings it started as a simple
Facebook page for the founder Dr Aaron
dossy to document his bug photography
hobby the guy has a thing for bugs
somewhere along the lines he got
intrigued by the idea of eating bugs as
food as one would but being unemployed
at the time he wasn't really going
anywhere with the idea until a friend
told him about research grants from The
Gates Foundation dosia applied on a whim
and he had no idea just how excited
Billy would be about his idea and so
Billy dropped $100,000 on all things
bugs so with this own savings and that
100k from Bill Gates the company was
born their mission statement is simple
we develop sustainable insect based
Solutions Technologies and products for
agriculture food and medicine and today
they have a hand in nearly every sector
of this new emerging bug protein
industry we've made various food
products using those ingredients
alternative Meats pastas cereals snacks
like cheese curls tortillas baked goods
they were the first company to develop a
tolerable insect based protein powder
Grio Pro a 100% Cricut protein powder
that you can buy right now to shove down
your throats they praise this powder for
having the lightest color and mildest
Aroma and flavor of any insect protein
available they guarantee on their
website that its smooth texture prevents
consumers from noticing any trace of
insect particulates you know Cricket
legs and stuff but they aren't just
researching how to make bugs into
something that passes us through food
now they're developing technology to
mass produce and harvest bugs on a
factory farm scale they've received
millions of funding from the US
Department of Agriculture and they've
also received funding from DARPA Yes you
heard that right DARPA why do bug
researchers need money from a government
Defense Agency well as it turns out
they're also doing a lot of research
into genetically engineering bugs sure
their focus is to make bugs into a more
nutritious food source but if the idea
of a massive factory of GMO bugs that
are ground into a food slurry for humans
sounds like the plot of a dystopian
sci-fi novel well it's because it does
but Bill Gates's bug philanthropy does
not stop there in 2021 The Gates
Foundation donated more than $2 million
to an insect Farm in Kenya called
insecty Pro they mostly use organic Wass
to raise fly larvae flies which they're
using to create animal feed yeah yeah
exactly because they try to look down
they don't like lights so they're going
to go through the holes in your hand
oh yes that is right even if you would
never eat insect protein directly soon
instead of eating a grass-fed steak you
could be eating an insect fed steak and
not even know about it yum they also
raise crickets for human consumption and
this Farm is just one of many already in
mass production raising over 1 trillion
bugs a year to feed both animals and
humans but bug food Bolas and insect
Farms aren't the only things Bill is
doing to eradicate
[Music]
Meats G has been touting the potential
of plant-based meat at least as early as
2013 he invested nearly $130 million
into beyond meat in 2019 he's invested
even more into their rival impossible
Foods protein based
approaches uh have surprised me how far
they've come in when they've been
offered in Burger chains uh the demand
has been quite good and he's invested
into lab grown meat as well by backing
companies like upside foods and you may
be thinking okay but why is this a bad
thing he can invest in whatever he wants
if people want to eat less meat me why
shouldn't they and if Bill Gates wants
to invest in these things he should be
allowed to it's a free country after all
right and yes it is and they can do
whatever they wants but what you got to
know is that plant-based meat and lav
grow meat are absolutely disgusting the
plant-based hee responsible for making
the impossible Burgers bleed comes from
genetically modified soybeans which have
extremely high levels of estrogen which
are also raised in massive amounts of
pesticides like monsanto's Roundup which
is linked to organ damage in animals
cancer and even non- hodkin lymphoma in
humans MC me is also known to include
MSG known neurotoxins and a giant long
list of synthetic additives it's
basically Ultra processed food taken to
a whole new extreme and lab grow meat is
not any better lab grow meat comes from
genetically modified animal cells that
have been immortalized to reproduce
super fast and forever they're basically
cancer cells these cancer cells are
banned by the FDA in regular food
production and there is zero safety data
on if using basically cancer cells and
food is safe these cells are also fed on
massive amounts of monocrop soybeans
which again are extremely high in
estrogen and to top it all off this
whole concoction requires a ton of
antibiotics to keep the mush from
putrifying and that carbon footprint is
supposed to reduce it turns out that
loud grow me is even worse than
conventional cattle farming but none of
that matters because Bill Gates does not
want these meat Replacements to be
optional he wants them to be the only
option in 2021 he said in an interview
you're right that's saying to people you
can't have cows anymore talk about a
politically unpopular approach to things
I do think all rich countries should
move to 100% synthetic beef you can get
used to the taste difference and the
claim is they're going to make it taste
even better over time event that green
premium is modest enough that you can
sort of change the behavior of people or
use regulation to totally shift the
demand a yes changing the behavior of
the masses using regulation to shift
demand these are the things that Bill
Gates and other elitist like him are
scheming up in their minds right now as
we speak and really fast if you want to
opt out of all this nonsense even if you
choose not to eat artificial meat or bug
meat like Bill Gates wants you to the
average meat you find in your grocery
store is not good hormone steroids
chlorine baths and maybe even mRNA
vaccines in the future are just some of
the things that could be in the meat in
your grocery store and when no country
of origin labeling requirements meat
from third world suppliers can be
repackaged and sold as American Meat
which is why I'm really happy to have
good ranchers sponsoring this video good
ranchers will ship you 100% American
Farm race meat straight to your door
that way you can get quality beef
chicken pork and seafood without
worrying what's in it or where it's
coming from all their meat is antibiotic
and vaccine free their beef is grass-fed
and USDA prime upper Choice which are
the two highest grades beef can receive
in America their Seafood is all wild
caught their chicken is better than
organic being antibiotic hormone and
vaccine free their entire lives and
their pork is the closest to Perfection
you can get since it's the holidays I
recommend the good ranchers Holiday
Helper box which has all the flavors of
fall like pumpkin spice bacon applewood
bacon alongside classic like spala
Heritage ham and good ranchers is giving
you guys $30 off any box along with free
express shipping so scroll down click
the link below and use proo code Jake
Tren to get this special discount that's
$30 off with code Jake tram with the
link
below but why why is he pushing this
what's his beef for just letting people
live their own
[Music]
lives Bill Gates is simple he's got all
the money in the world he sees himself
as one of the brightest Minds who is
destined to save the world and he is
absolutely desperate to leave a legacy
but most importantly Bill Gates had the
unfortunate fate of being born in the
shadow of a great man few people realize
that Bill Gates is not the first Bill
Gates he's not even the second now his
name is William Gates III and like any
man raising his son to be the next one
to run the dynasty Bill Gates Senor left
some pretty big shoes for him to fill my
dad is is somebody I aspire to to live
up to what he's done Bill Gates Senor
founded his own Law Firm he was the
chairman of organizations like Planned
Parenthood and United Way and he was a
big- time philanthropist himself former
President Jimmy Carter sang his Praises
for Bill Gates Senor for his charity
work in Africa and when you're born into
a rich successful family like this you
often grow up never feeling like you're
enough never feeling like you can ever
make your parents proud all of us tend
to want to make our parents proud of us
at the end of the day and what whatever
that means for each person and the
problem is that it's very difficult to
to to actually make your parents proud
if your parents were individuals who you
know kind of came from nothing and
became multi-billionaires or whatever
might be the case and so they end up
being extremely insecure people if if
anything um they're they're among the
most sort of insecure people that I've
met and then also they grow up in these
elite private schools that make life
very difficult for them because they're
comparing themselves to other kids who
also have extremely wealthy parents
usually there are enough kids out there
with even wealthier parents and so their
standard like their bare minimum
standard standard of success is so high
that it's functionally impossible to
achieve really and that ends up making
them have extremely low self-esteem they
act really weird this is probably the
Deep rooted insecurity of Bill Gates and
when Bill Gates created The Gates
Foundation in the 9s it was a well-known
fact that Gates Senior was the primary
force to push his son to pursue the
projects He did well my dad has set an
example by what he does they both
donated to a lot of the same projects
Bill Gates Senor actually ran his son's
foundation for years you know he's the
one who really got the Foundation going
encouraged me to give early uh got us
involved in some very key causes and
helped us build what is uh now a strong
group of people that I I get to work
with full-time so it shouldn't be a
surprise that Bill Gates is obsessed
with things like funding vaccines in
Africa or climate change in
overpopulation he approaches his charity
projects the same way he sees running a
company like Microsoft when I you know
say okay we're going to build a TB drug
team we're going to build the TB vaccine
team we're going to build them kill all
the mosquitoes in the world genan Drive
crisper team I get to in terms of how we
fund that organize it how many locations
do we wait till they have this result
before we scale it up I get to use the
same or 80% the same type of thinking
that I exercised in terms of okay let's
go do windows let's go do Excel and it's
very comfortable because the most
intense period of Microsoft was where
these teams were about size 30 but yes I
feel like my working with governments
hiring smart people managing teams it
did prepare me well for this very
operational organization that's a lot
like a business except that we're our
profit is Liv saved as opposed to a
monetary measur and what kind of a
person was he in the early days of
Microsoft well it's a well-known fact
that he was the office bully it was
normal for employees to receive
sarcastic emails at 2: in the morning
calling their code the stupidest piece
of code ever written End quotes their
office meetings had one person whose
only job it was to tally how many times
Gates angrily dropped the f- word
because the lower the number the better
things were for the team one employe
remembers quote his standard MO is to
ask harder and harder questions until
you admit that you don't know and then
he can yell at you for being unprepared
End quotes Gates almost never left the
office and he was known to eat orange
tank powder out of his hand rather than
take breaks or stop for meals I mean it
really is true that I didn't believe in
weekends I didn't believe in vacations
and he was just as neurotic about making
sure everyone else is working just as
hard as he was I knew everybody's
license plate so I could tell you over
the last month when their car had come
and gone from the the parking lot this
is the kind of control freak energy that
he is putting behind climate change and
right now his sworn enemy behind climate
change are cows agriculture is
responsible for 24% of the world's
greenhouse gases and cattle are a major
emitter of methane which is more potent
than CO2 add to that the fear of human
overpopulation and gase is convinced
that there won't be enough protein to
feed everyone without destroying the
planets all these fears are unfounded by
the way which we'll go over later but
here's the real question what is his
grand plan for eliminating
[Music]
cattle if the masses cannot be persuaded
by consumerism to change their behavior
government intervention is Billy's next
step and one of the ways to do that is
with subsidies subsidies are a fancy
word for giving away free money for
things like growing corn or for electric
vehicles if the government gives out
bonuses for actions they want people to
take they will get more of those actions
and as it turns out fake me is starting
to get a lot of subsidies governments
from all over have already thrown over a
billion dollars at it and they are just
getting started so while edible insects
haven't been subsidized much yet that
might change very soon President Biden
signed an executive order this year
requiring federal agencies to support
cultivating alternative food sources
Federal Regulators are now deciding how
lab grown meat must be labeled the final
step before for public sale and it isn't
just the White House saying this either
our good friends at the world economic
Forum are also pushing for fake meat and
bugs too like this article Burgers bugs
and the shift to a new way of eating but
of course subsidies are only half of the
coin to eliminating cattle subsidies are
like the carrots but regulations are the
stick and a few countries around the
world have already tried using the stick
approach to ban beef in 2019 Dutch
Farmers revolted when the Government
tried to force them to kill off half of
the country's livestock Irish farmers
are being pressured to kill off hundreds
of thousands of cows and New Zealand has
proposed a leral fart tax to reduce
emissions and limit the number of cattle
the population is exploding cattle
farming is killing our planets we have
to do something but what if all these
excuses are not the whole
[Music]
[Applause]
story overpopulation the big scare of
Bill Gates we're not going to have
enough food to feed the world so bug
meat of course but the truth is that we
have no no idea how many humans the
Earth can actually sustain population
control groups have been fighing over
the number for decades the numbers have
ranged from less than 1 billion to more
than a trillion or even one sextilion
which means none of them actually have
any idea what they're talking about on
top of that overp population is actually
the exact opposite of what we should be
worried about we should actually be
worried about population collapse what
we Face uh is population collapse huh
collapse like people have no idea how
fast the population is going to collapse
there is a jaw-dropping global crash in
the number of children being born the US
fertility rate has been below the
minimum replacement rate for decades and
China's population is predicted to drop
in half by the year 2100 so is
Japan's and while developing countries
still have high fertility rates those
will also drop as their countries
improve so don't buy into Bill gates'
fearmongering eat meat and have kids but
what about his whole spiel about all the
methane produced from cows well as it
turns out the cattle are not the problem
industrial farming is the problem
healthy Farms can actually be an
important sync for CO2 and methis like
regenerative farming have shown that
cattle farming can actually be Net Zero
not to mention it's also way more Humane
at the end of the day humans were meant
to eat meat no matter what the vegans
want you to think think about it humans
were never as fat and sick as we are
today and the only thing that has
changed about our food from then and now
is that now we have processed foods now
we have meat raised with antibiotics
corn and soy but you know bling
grass-fed meat that has been around for
Millennia as the cause of all diseases
no matter how hard Billy tries Ultra
processed plant-based meat lab grown
meat and bug meat will never be able to
compare and by the way Guys near the end
of this month I am going to be dropping
perhaps the most important series I've
ever made on this channel if you felt a
certain uneasiness in the air the last
couple of years if you feel as if the
country and the world is headed towards
a cliff and there's no stopping it you
are not alone because all the tension
and Chaos that's in the era right now
was all predicted in an old book written
almost 30 years ago called the fourth
turning in this book the authors
explained that history literally repeats
itself in 80 to 100e Cycles which is
around the length of one human lifetime
each one of these Cycles starts with a
crisis and ends with a crisis usually
something catastrophic like a war before
the cycle starts all over again and this
has happened over and over and over
again World War II was the last crisis
then the Civil War before that then the
Revolutionary War before that and
surprise surprise all these catastrophic
events are all magically around 80 years
apart but this is not because of some
Grand conspiracy no it's because of
simple predictable human nature World
War II ended in 1945 which means it's
been 7 8 years since the last crisis
which means we're right on schedule to
face something big in the next few years
a life altering event that will make the
elites like Bill Gates even more rich
and Powerful while the middle class and
the poor will get squeezed one final
time just like what we saw during Co and
in this three-part series as dropping at
the end of the month we're going to go
over what the cycles of history teaches
us about our future what to expect and
most importantly how to prepare so you
can take advantage of this crisis to
join this drop for free all you have to
do is click the card on the screen or
click the link below sign up where your
name and email it takes like 11 seconds
and we'll give you everything you need
to know once the series is ready so you
can be the first to watch click the card
on the screen to join this drop
now